this episode is sponsored by awesome
socks club a sock subscription
for charity click the link in the
description to sign up between now and
december 11th to get a new pair of fun
socks
each month in 2021
[Music]
for all of us on the micro cosmos team
stenters
are the gift that is always giving they
were the first
organism we did a deep dive episode on
because we wanted more people
to get a chance to appreciate how
magnificent this
very unappreciated unicellular organism
is and now with our fancy new dic
microscope
we've gotten the chance to appreciate
their magnificence
in new ways it is amazing how
changing bits of light can give you a
new perspective
scientists have been studying stenters
for well over a century
and that's given them plenty of time to
find
new ways to learn about them and
sometimes
those methods are pretty normal for
example in 1995
there were reports that a lake in
germany had turned black
and there was a clear culprit a large
number of stenter
amethystinis and for one group of
scientists
this black spot bloom was an opportunity
to put their plankton nets to good use
and collect some samples
they gathered the stenter amethystines
particularly
to study the purplish pigment amethystin
that gives the species its name
isolating the molecule so they could
determine its structure
and compare it to other pigments the
coloring is unique among stenters and it
stands out particularly when you compare
it to the vivid blue of stenter corulius
stenter corulius gets its color from a
pigment called stenterin
which helps the stenter respond to light
and also
serves a defensive function and while
stenter corulius
is a much-studied organism this pigment
has turned up in strange places
in the mid-2000s people began observing
that the blue catfish of eufaula lake in
oklahoma
were producing some strange eggs
nothing was wrong with them but they
were a reddish purple color
roughly a quarter of the female catfish
were laying
purple eggs instead of their normal
yellowish cream-colored eggs
and when scientists investigated further
they found that the ovaries of the
female catfish
had become purple as well all that color
came from stenterin the lake had likely
experienced blooms of stinter corulius
which accumulated in the lake after the
release of organic pollutants
as the stenter's numbers increased so
did their consumption by catfish
and that then drove to the accumulation
of stenter and inside the catfish's
ovaries
affecting the color of the eggs stinter
corulius's color makes it easy to spot
but other species can be more difficult
to tell apart
we've labeled this one stenter rosely
but to be completely honest
we're not sure if that's exactly what it
is
it might be a similar looking species
called stenter magnus
but we can't tell them apart just by
looking at them
if we had a stenter magnus and a stenter
roselie side by side
we could not tell you just by looking at
them whether they were the same organism
there is however a weird and gruesome
way to solve that mystery
it's called grafting to start
you take your two mystery stenters and
you cut them in half
then you quickly take half of stenter
number one
and press it to half of center number
two at the exposed edge of both
organisms
because they're stunters and amazingly
good at regeneration
the two halves will fuse together like
a frankenstein's microbe if your two
original stenters are the same species
that fusion
will survive if they are two different
species
most likely it will die though intrepid
stenter's stitches
have found that the degree to which
these different halves are incompatible
varies with different species and
different combinations
and we don't know for certain which ones
will work just that it's a thing that
maybe we should test out ourselves one
day
underlying grafting is that remarkable
regenerative ability of stenters which
we've described
at length before but to summarize
stenters
are just really good at rebuilding
themselves when they need to
maybe you're looking at this unicellular
organism and thinking well
it's just one cell how complicated can
it be
pretty complicated it turns out so
complicated that we still
don't really know how this regeneration
works scientists have been trying to
figure this out for over a century
and the mystery remains unsolved though
at this point
at least very well documented and for
more than a century
scientists have been passing down
techniques to cut stenters
into pieces there's the obvious surgical
technique using a needle to cut a
stunter into pieces and then
watch it reconstruct several new
versions of itself
but you can also bathe stenters in a
sugar solution
and the organism will then shed its oral
apparatus which
is its version of a mouth it's not clear
why this happens but it allows
scientists to watch the stenter rebuild
that one portion of its body
scientists used this method to study how
stinter corulius resets the movement of
its cilia
after regenerations cilia may look like
little bits of
hair lining the organism but they act
more like a coordinated set of limbs
that help draw in food and move the
stenter around
lots and lots of limbs that are moving
together in a complex dance that
in turn creates patterns of movement in
the water
surrounding the center and the
scientists watched as the stenters
were able to rebuild this whole complex
system again they found that it takes
about five hours just to grow those oral
cilia back to an observable length and
then another
two hours for the cilia to start
coordinating their movements
so much work went into understanding the
timeline of this one
narrow process in regeneration and there
is still
so much mechanical mystery underlying it
not to mention all the other feats of
regenerative prowess that stunters
casually perform on a regular basis
but science is always advancing
and with all these mysteries to solve
and more
stenters will likely find themselves at
the center of many
many other strange experiments and
observations
to come thank you for coming on this
journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
now i'm gonna go out on a limb here and
assume that you person
listening to this wear sucks sometimes
and what if i told you that you could
get new socks while also giving to
charity
well that's precisely what the awesome
socks club is all about it's a charity
sock subscription where 100
of after tax profit will go to decrease
maternal and child mortality in sierra
leone
the socks are fun and attractive and
subscribers will get a different pair
designed by a different designer every
month of 2021
but so we can control inventory and
reduce waste signups are only going to
be available
until december 11th so if this sounds
like a club you'd like to be a part of
head on over to awesomesocks.com
microcosmos to sign up or just click the
link in the description and remember
you have to sign up by december 11th
thank you as always to all of these
people here
they are our patrons they make it
possible for us to make content like
this
for everyone who wants to see it if
you'd like to join up with them and also
get some cool little perks
you can check out patreon.com
journeytomicro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button
somewhere nearby
[Music]